Loosen up your belt.
Let's take a moment to give thanks for Thanksgiving.
To most Americans, the Pilgrims of Plymouth, Massachusetts...
...are the iconic inspiration for today's Thanksgiving feast.
After the winter of 1620 killed almost half of their people,...
...the colonists formed a relationship with the neighboring Wampanoag tribe...
...who taught them about fishing, planting, and hunting.
By autumn of 1621, the colonists had collected enough food...
...to feed the community through the coming winter.
The Wampanoags joined the colonists for a three-day feast in honor of their bounty.
The feast probably did not include our modern Thanksgiving staple, turkey.
In 1863, four months after the victory at Gettysburg,...
...he declared the last thursday of November to be Thanksgiving Day.
Most of all, Thanksgiving is about family.
With modern life moving faster than ever,...
...Thanksgiving gives us a day to take a collective breath,...
...reconnect with loved ones,...
...and remember just how much we have to be thankful for.